et producteurs de blé à saint-robert
monsieur capelette comment allez vous
bonjour oui ça va bien bon vous dis
qu'est ce que ça change le contexte
mondial le prix du blé qui a explosé la
rareté en fête du blé compte tenu de
l'embargo russe sur le blé ukrainien et
c est ce que ça change quelque chose
dans votre marché à vous
aubin sur mer c'est sûr que si on parle
d'avant des sanglots on a signé des
contrats quand même possible et
alimentation humaine le à peu près trop
195 dollars la tonne en prêt fermé qui
présente mais là aussi je revendrai le
monde lit il vaudrait à peu près cinq
cent cinquante tout près de 125 150
parallèlement 600 dollars la tonne le 4
on parle d'un bilan qui répondent aux
critères l'alimentation humaine ce qui
veut dire que sa pratique mais pas
d'oublier la mer 30 40 pour cent par
rapport au prix meli prix qu'on a déjà
fait ses débuts ferme fait que le blé
est beau et d'engins par ce qui veut
dire que moi comme agriculteur cette
année par rapport à ce prix de blé le
qui est vendu pour 7 fournisseurs l'eau
qui fait de la farine pour les
boulangers mais pratiquement pas de
hausse la poursuite ils vont en avoir
mais pour l'an prochain plus le pour
cette année ça va être à peu près la
même chose pour d'amis proches à
moelleux comme agriculteur cette année
mais cette importance que vous expliquer
ce que vous aviez des contrats signés
l'an dernier et que vous même si le prix
mondial monde pose pas comme les sens on
ne peut pas monter vos prix à mesure que
la saison avance là
bas une fois quelques retrouvent parce
que le client avec qui on fait un festin
c'est quelqu'un qui fait de la farine
pour l'heure plusieurs boulangers là au
québec meq lui sa procédure c'est en
général ce qui à rapt est des
améliorations à faire mais les les
contrôles sont au château vous faites à
prix ferme à l'année à 20 de sommeil ses
tubes les divers qui est sommée exemple
en septembre fait les contrats sont
signés fax à tout était fait oui avant
os nommé on parle quand même le 2 ça
décrit notre lot mais le même blé le
même but aujourd'hui six rapports
doivent quand même les locaux de
celui-ci sera en vente sur le marché
aujourd'hui
il ya rennes vraiment noces look est qui
qui qui qui sera mon cher autour de 5,50
e puis vous pouvez pas vous retournez
plaisir à votre client mais je revendrai
sur le marché lève pas comme ça que ça
se fait là
non non les exemples les contrecoups
notre fête avec ces compagnies là sont
fermées sont dédiés à cette définition
l'eau mais exemple y blick son post
contrat avec un zoo ben ça fait un peu
comique là mais si je veux être capable
de vendre mes autres blé qui vont un
marché moi j'appelle sur fourrages une
qui vaut pour les poulets puis pour les
pâles mais deux papas deux fois mais 40%
des 200 pièces l'attend plus cher que ce
que je veux faire dans qualité
alimentaire pour l'année qui s'en vient
fadel fall la hausse théorique a
représenté comme
le blé g 20 et 22 cents dedans à la
normale dans un sac dans un panier de
1.4 piège à peu près 20 et 22 cents avec
la hausse du marché s'y rapportent deux
pays fermé mais ça a pu commander un peu
d'un dizaine de scènes ce qui veut dire
un trou à pourcin c'est ma partie comme
agriculteur l'oci exemple le prix a
répété pharma sa a représenté comme trop
% d'augmentation sur le prix que le
consommateur au a payé par rapport au
prix que moi comme agriculteur je reçois
mes des producteurs comme vous qui ont
signé des contrats fermes et vous fait
pas la passe passez moi l'expression
compte tenu de l'augmentation du prix du
blé mondial
non ça va être baissé sol est un
acheteur qui est assez majeur le qui en
fait plusieurs comme ça c'est contre
l'aso c'est ce que son portefeuille
dachau est acheteur logitech diversifiée
à travers le canada c'est peut-être pas
tout fait d' avance mais la partie qui
est fait est que les agriculteurs du
québec l'oim en grande majorité s'est
dit plus que sont fermées au moment du
semis en septembre 2002 21 ok je vais
montrer une image c'est parce que
j'allais la voix mais d'un pain puis on
avait fait ça la dernière fois le la
partie qui vous revient à vous sur un
pain qui coûte 4 $ 25 il ya 22 ans ou
qui s'en va à vous il ya 73 6 av à la
transformation en farine
une et 90 sur boulanger qu'une et 40 au
détail ans à peu près cela chaîne
ouais ouais en gros le tableau est pas
mal pas mal je lève un oui je l'avais
consulter à l'époque le web ça
représente pas mal ce qui se passe lors
dans la chaîne de transmission la du
produit le keeper de la ferme
chemin-vert les transformateurs de
farine pas près sur tout le circuit de
deux traces de boulangerie pas pressé de
ces cui de distribution marketing etc
qui sera jouable de sueur et donc
j'avais pas la plus grosse partie une
évidente
non non non c'est ce que la
savoie comme se répercute et encore plus
l'an prochain parce que tout le système
continue comme ça mais c'est ce qu'en
septembre 2022 quand on va signer nos
contrat pour l'an prochain et 2023 mais
si c'est encore le même contexte de
rareté mais là les prix auront peu de
choix de ce site réajuster parce que ça
soit et les agriculteurs vendent et ben
on va faire d'autres blessés on va faire
du blé à d'autres à d'autres ados de
destiner le si si c'est pour corriger
mais pour l'instant pas quand on voit le
prix moi je regarde le prix du pain qui
maintenant qu'est tendance à monter ben
je me dis bien et encore moins comme
agriculteur l'ofsp au moins qu'ils
disent pour moi qui pour moi comme
agriculteur qui en profitent le présente
mal dans sa peau pour ceux qui ont fait
des contrats à prix ferme est ce pas
notre cas pour elle le présente mail
c'est ce qu'on voulait clair avec vous
mais le choc tarifaire le choc des prix
pour arriver l'an prochain quand tous
les contrôles vont sera négocié à voir
on vous reparlera parler - du temps où
on voit la lumière qui est
extraordinaire à saint robert
vous avez écrit deux articles déjà et
l'été et même pas commencé sur la
sécheresse
quel est l'état de la situation puis
qu'est ce que vous devez faire pour
pallier au manque d'eau
ben on a appuyé d'un deux dernières
années là on a eu 2 2 de sucre et une
deux années vraiment sèche le des années
historiques l'appui on ne modifie un peu
nos choses l'emportant en est quand même
bien sorti avec une année qui avait été
piqué l'année 2020
gardella au printemps là on a une belle
puis la lundi je me trompe pas
l'associer à coeur du jeu un peu la
situation mais on est correct le lycée
réalmont dans l'autre camp nou l'oubli
du vol c'est bon c'est une nouvelle
culture qu'on est en train de se remet
présentement que le statut sec mais avec
la pluie qu'on a eu on a gagné du temps
puis c'est certain que nous autres on
travaille beaucoup le côté
conservation des sols protection du
sentir au beau soleil en semaine crème
solaire mais maintenant au sol ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'avec les changements
climatiques les hautes températures
c'est qu'on s'organise pour avoir
découvert végétaux qui devient un peu
comme une protection pour le sol avec le
soleil tape moins sur le sol directement
facile à l'évaporation on est capable de
garder plus notre cap des notes au congo
il a conservé pour la paire dames en
évaporation fait que ça ça nous aide
beaucoup le sait ce qui nous a aidés
beaucoup en 2021 c'est ce qu'on a répété
en 2002 quand je voyais le scénario si
chaud si tôt qu'après deux semaines plus
vite tout les records qu'on n'avait
jamais vu de l'air sec pas de rose et un
autant de réponses et pas de pluie ce
qui faisait pas beaucoup de réserve on a
quand même une belle hiver et naïve mais
si la réserve mais tant que c'est comme
si on roulait avec une marge de crédit
tout d'assurer une carte de crédit tout
petit bar de la limite de desfossés fait
que c'est il faut vouloir tout à gérer
notre pire reste hélas aux aguets mais
là au moins il ya puis qu'on eut parce
qu'ils nous annoncent vendredi
probablement ça va nous donner encore du
gazole pour être capable d'indiquer aux
autres coderre de leur énergie par
rapport aux plantes la guadeloupe a dit
le beau robert lemay dans les bonnes
raisons merci gérez vous voir le dico on
va on veut refaire le point plus tard
dans quelques semaines sur les sur votre
monde puis vous des filles paul
capelette producteurs de blé à
saint-robert merci nous avons parlé
merci et merci vous êtes tous les
bienvenus massive ou quoi